Speaker 1: This is a very interesting and
important clip that I'm going to play for
you. This is video of Dr. Karen Berg explaining
to a bunch of Kentucky senators, mostly white men,
how fetal development works. A really,
really interesting clip, which the clip
itself is from March 10th, but it went viral a
couple of days ago. Article in Women's Agenda.
You were killing women. Senator Karen Berg
slams Kentucky's restrictive abortion bill.
I am the only woman on this podium. I
am the only physician on this podium.
This bill is a medical sham. It does not follow
medicine. It does not even purport to listen to
medicine. Now, Kentucky Senator Karen Berg is
not only a senator, she is also a medical doctor,
and she I don't, you know, I would say ranted.
But Rant has like a negative connotation. This
was a very fact-based, impassioned plea to again
what is basically just white men deciding about
abortion and what women should be allowed
to do. Explaining how things actually work,
let's take a listen to this and
Speaker 5: explain my novel. Yes, ma'am.
You know, I'm a diagnostic radiologist and
diagnostic radiologists historically and in many
places in this state still do all of the first
trimester OB ultrasound. So I am extraordinarily
personally familiar with the development of a
fetus in the womb, right? And for you to sit here
and say that at 15 weeks, a fetus has a functional
heart, a for chamber heart that can survive on its
own is fallacious. That is not true. There is
no viability. You know, if I look around at my
colleagues on this committee, I am the only woman
on this podium right now. I am the only physician
sitting on this podium. This bill is a net
uphold sham. It does not follow medicine.
It does not even purport to listen to medicine.
And for each and every one of my colleagues to
be so willing to cast and I vote when what you are
doing is putting your finger, pointing your knee,
putting your. A gun to women said you are killing
women because abortion will continue. Women will
continue to have efficacy over their own
body, whether or not you make it legal.
I vote no. And I really, really apologize to
the people in Kentucky that we are spending
this much time and this much energy. When we
have families and poverty, we have single women
heading households in poverty at a higher rate
than any other group in the state. And you all are
not addressing that. You all are making it worse.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So this has actually become I
don't want to call it a meme, but it has become
a kind of self-replicating talking point about 15
weeks. Now what's important? So and the hesitation
I have to see, there's a double edged sword here.
And I'll tell you what it is, which is. You
can address these claims individually and say,
is there anything to this 15 week, the heartbeat
viability thing? And we'll talk about that in a
second. But sometimes the problem is if you start
engaging specifically with some of these things,
it ignores the bigger issue, which is generally
speaking, clueless people making decisions about
women's bodies and particularly people who will
never have to make those decisions for themselves
because they're mostly men, as we've seen time
and time again in many of these southern states
making decisions about abortion. But
let's at least explore the talking point,
which is it's been mentioned now in multiple
states Kentucky, Mississippi, other places.
The talking point is the heart is viable at 15
weeks, at 15 weeks, and we have to we have to
consider that. And so therefore there should be no
abortion ever allowed after 15 weeks is typically
what what they say. You can argue about how fully
developed the heart is at 15 weeks. And I don't
mean you can argue there is one scientific
answer, but you can make that the focus.
But the truth is that until week 22 or 23,
there's no fetal viability outside of the womb.
And you know, if you could research this and
it's widely written about that at that point
at 23 weeks, it's a very, very marginal
in terms of fetal viability and very, very
low percentage. That's 23 weeks. And they're,
you know, parroting this 15 week thing. Tate
Reeves, the Mississippi governor, recently did
it on a recently. In the last six months or so,
there was an incident where he was on CNN, and he
talked about it as well, and it's just not true.
But simply simply debunking that there is a
question as to whether that's even the right way
to fight these people. Because there's the bigger
question of who, who are they really to say about
this stuff anyway? I mean, it's when we look
at the some of the questions asked yesterday
of Judge Kitten's You, Brown Jackson,
during her confirmation hearings.
Are there physical differences between
men and women? Are babies racist?
What is your opinion? What is the definition
of a woman or should? Is some private school
in Washington, D.C. teach from a certain book or
whatever the case may be. You can argue each of
those things on the merits, but it's sort of like
she's interviewing, quote, interviewing to be a
Supreme Court justice. Whatever the answer is,
does it really have relevance in the field that
she is going to be in? And it's sort of a similar
thing with the abortion debate, which is, to some
degree, the individual fights about heartbeats and
viability and all these different things that they
are not really the main issue, which is these are
people who want to decide for women. What it is
that they should be able to decide for themselves,
and it's not like if you win the argument about
heart development at 15 weeks. Their perspective
is going to be changed. So that's why a question
about the kind of wisdom of engaging in that. I
don't know. I'm curious to hear from you guys.